bonjour je m'appelle Stéphanie Fleury
j'ai 25 ans j'habite Saint-Denis j'ai le
permis B et je recherche un poste de
collaboratrice en cabinet dans l'Audi ou
la comptabilité j'ai actuellement une
licence DCG diplôme de la comptabilité
de la gestion que j'ai effectué en
alternance et par la suite j'ai effectué
le DSCG diplôme supérieur de la
comptabilité de la gestion et j'ai
travaillé en alternance au Crédit
Immobilier de France en métropole
ensuite j'ai aussi effectué deux stages
de deux mois chacun
à BDO et aussi à Carrefour finance par
la suite j'ai aussi travaillé à
l'étranger un an
en Inde
où j'ai travaillé en collaboration avec
un hôpital Fortis et puis dernièrement
j'effectue un stage de deux mois à BVA
audité conseil j'ai longtemps fait de la
danse classique et moderne jazz
à côté de ça j'aime beaucoup lire et
j'aime voyager
je suis quelqu'un de dynamique et
réactive j'ai le sens des
responsabilités j'aime gérer les
imprévus je suis quelqu'un d'assidu et
j'ai une grande conscience
professionnelle je suis actuellement
disponible n'hésitez pas à me contacter
et je vous répondrai avec plaisir